مجزره بشعه لا يمكن تجاهلها بهذه الكلمات
علق الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب على
مجزره خان شيخون التي اودت بحياه عشرات
الاشخاص اغلبهم من الاطفال في موقف اشد
قوه وشهد الخارجيه البريطانيه اصبع
الاتهام مباشره لنظام الاسد وبالتزامن مع
ذلك دعى الرئيس الفرنسي فرانسوا اولاند
الى عمل يرقى الى فداحه المجزره عمل قد
يكون بدا بتقديم مشروع قرار ارادت به
واشنطن ولندن وباريس اثبات ضلوع النظام
السوري في الجريمه النكراء من خلال تحقيق
دقيق بد ان تحقيقات سابقه اوفت بهذا الهدف
باشراف اممي لتجد في طريقها موسكو الجاهزه
بحق النقض وبتعويض روايات الهجمات لتحول
بها ردود الفعل الغاضبه ال صرخه تتبدد في
التفاصيل اللاحقه للصراع في بلاد الشام هل
سيتكرر السيناريو القديم ام اننا ازاء
منعرج سيقود لمحاسبه بشار الاسد ومعاقبته
نصر ايت ال طاهر والتقرير التالي قبل
البدء في
النقاش ايش تحقه بسياره اسعاف يا شيخ الى
متى في السؤال سخط واستنكار لكن ايضا حيره
وعجز عجز امام قتاله الابرياء في سوريا مع
ذلك فقد استحال الصمت امام جثث هامده اخرى
ومزيد من حالات التشنج
والاختناق سمع السوريون تنديدا عالميا
بمجزره خان شيخون الكيميائيه وادانه تفاوت
وضوحها لنظام الاسد لكن الواضحه في واشنطن
ان الحديث المتعجل هناك عن ان الاسد ليس
اولويه امريكيه قد تراجع امام ما بدا
للبعض حرجا اخلاقيه صار البيت الابيض
يتحدث عن عمل مشين ارتكبه النظام السوري
وشكل اهانه رهيبه
للانسانيه وسريعا انضم الامريكيون الى
حراك في مجلس الامن اطلقته لندن وباريس
التين تقدم موقفهما بضع خطا على بقيه
العواصم الاوروبيه
لكن الروس ما كانوا ليقبلوا بمشروع القرار
الغربي المطالب بلجنه تحقيق
امميه كم من الاطفال يجب ان يموتوا بعد
لكي تبدي موسكو اهتماما بالامر المندوبه
الامريكيه في الامم المتحده هي من يسال
يبدو ان واشنطن تلقفت اسباب تمادي الاسد
في دمويته تدرك انه سيستمر في استخدام
الاسلحه الكيميائيه ضد شعبه اذا لقي من
يعترض كل مسع دولي لادانته بل ويحيك
سيناريوات بديله لهجماته بالاسلحه المحرمه
دوليه لذلك انتهك مرارا القرار الدولي رقم
218 الذي تبناه مجلس الامن ردا على مجزره
الغوطه الشرقيه عام
2013 لا غروه في ان المعارضه السوريه تعد
المجزره دليلا اخر على انه لا يمكن
التفاوض مع نظام ادمن الاجرام وانه لا
قيمه ل ادنه يشارك فيها الضامن بالجريمه
انها تطالب بادراج نظام الاسد على قائمه
مجرمي الحرب وااله القضيه مع الحالات
السابقه الى محكمه الجنايات الدوليه لكن
الا يفترض ان واشنطن اشرفت مع موسكو على
تفكيك الترسانه الكيميائيه السوريه بعد
اتفاقيتها ما في العام ذاته فمن اين جاءت
الاسلحه السامه المستخدمه في هجمه خان
شيخون ذاك ما يرجى من تحقيقات منظمه حظر
الاسلحه الكيميائيه ان تحدده الى جانب
الفاعل مع ان تحقيقات من ذلك القبيل لم
تنصف بعد ضحايا هجمات عديده سابقه
بالغازات السامه في سوريا وتلك هجمات لا
تخفي اداره دونالد ترامب بانها جزء من
سلوكيات نتجت عن ضعف الاداره الامريكيه
السابقه وانعدام التصميم لديها فماذا تغير
الان يقول الرئيس الامريكي ان خطوط كثيره
قد تم تجاوزها عندما جرى قتل الاطفال
والنساء وان لديه مسؤوليه بخصوص التعامل
مع الهجوم الكيميائي الاخير الذي نفذه
النظام السوري فهل لكلام كهذا ترجمه
عسكريه او قضائيه او حتى سياسيه ليس
معروفا بعد فحتى عندما سئل دونالد ترامب
وهو يستقبل العاهل الاردنيه في مكتبه
البيضوي عما اذا كان يعمل على صياغه سياسه
جديده بشان سوريا اكتف بالقول سوف
ترون انضم الينا من اسطنبول جورج صبره عضو
الهيئه العليا للمفاوضات لقوى الثوره
السوريه ومن لندن سمير بوري المحاضر في
الدراسات الامنيه في كينجز كوليج لنبدا
معك سيد سمير وانت في لندن وهي عاصمه
غربيه التي سمعنا منها ومن عواصم اخرى من
باريس ومن واشنطن تصريحات نود ان نقراها
ونقف عندها قويه بالفعل لكن باعتقادك الى
اي مدى قد تكون كافيه لتشكل
انعطاف فيما يخص الموقف من النظام السوري
لمحاسبته وربما
معاقبته كلا هذه تصريحات لا ترقى الى
مستوى تغيير الموقف اتجاه سوريا راين
فرنسا ولندن
ودول غربيه اخرى وعواصم غربيه اخرى خرجت
بتصريحات قويه ولكن المشكل في هذه العجله
الضخمه هي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التي تبدو ان لها لا تتوفر على سياسه
متجانسه تجاه سوريا واعتقد ان
العلاقه ايجابيه ما بين بوتين وترامب
ستلقي بدلالها على امكانيات الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في اتخاذ مواقف واضحه
وحازم تجاه سوريا من اجل التحرك باتجاه حل
سياسي شامل وعادل في سوريا نعم هناك اسئله
كثيره هل سنرى عمل على الارض بعد
التصريحات القويه كما تفضلت دعني استطلع
وجهه نظر السيد جورج صبرا سمعنا بالفعل
تصريحات قويه ما جاء ايضا على لسان ترامب
بانه موقفه من الازمه السوريه برمتها ومن
النظام السوري قد تغير وقد تغير كثيرا
وبانه لن يسكت عما حدث هل نتوقع بالفعل ان
تقدم هذه الاداره الامريكيه على ربما قرن
هذه الاقوال بافعال الامر الذي لم تفعله
الاداره السابقه والتي يعيبه ترامب
عليها حقيقه نحن نامل ان يحصل ذلك وهناك
مؤشرات في جلسه اليوم لانه من معيب حقا ان
تنحدر السياسه الى هذا الدرك وكذلك ان
تتهشم منظومه القيم الانسانيه قيم الانسان
كانسان في هذا العصر الى هذه الدرجه التي
تجري فيها جرائم موصوفه جرائم حرب جرائم
ضد الانسانيه وتجد تغطيه وتبرير من قبل
دول تدعي انها عظمى ومن اعلى منبر م يجب
ان يحمي الانسان يجب ان يحمي الدول
والمجتمعات وهو الامم المتحده هذه
المؤشرات ايجابيه وردت على لسان المندوب
البريطاني والفرنسي ولكن بطريقه اوضح على
لسان المندوبه الامريكيه عندما اتهمت بشكل
مبطن الاداره الروسيه بانها
تواط على ابقاء زء من السلاح الكيماوي بيد
بشار الاسد عندما لم تقم بما يجب من اجل
شجب هذه الاعتداءات وادانتها وعمل ما
يتوجب لنزع هذا السلاح الكيماوي كذلك ايضا
كان هناك فكره قويه عندما تحدثت المندوبه
الامريكيه ان الامم المتحده هي ميدان
للعمل الجماعي ولكن عندما تعجز ان تقوم
جماعيا بما يتوجب عليها اي حفظ الامن
والسلام وحفظ حياه الناس لابد من التوجه
نحو العمل الفردي ونحن نامل من اداره
الرئيس الامريكي الجديد ان تتجاوز كل
اخطاء وخطايا الاداره السابقه ليس فقط بحق
السوريين وحدهم انما بحق المنطقه وكذلك
اصدقاء الولايات الم على اي مستوى سيد
جورج الان في خبر عاجل موسكو مره اخرى وقد
كان ذلك متوقعا تماما تلوح بانها ستستخدم
حق الفيتو ان يعني قدم مشروع القرار هذا
دون استشارتها السؤال بالفعل يتساءل يعني
هذا الغطاء الروسي الذي للاسف الشديد لا
يستر لا [__] موسكو التي سقطت اخلاقيا
وسياسيا ولا حتى سوت هذا النظام السوري
الى متى من بمقدوره الضغط على موسكو لتضغط
على هذا النظام النظام
السوري يبدو ان السياسه الروسيه لا تريد
مغادره موقعها في العداء للشعب السوري هذا
الموقع الذي وضعت نفسها فيه منذ زمن
واستجم خلال مجريات العام الماضي
2016 وما يفعله الروس من فبركه قصص وح
حكايات تزيف الحقائق هو ليس عدوان على
الشعب السوري فقط انما بالفعل ليس فيه
احترام لعقول البشريه لعقول الدول التي
يجلسون معها في قاعات مجلس الامن لذلك
يتوجب على الجميع على جميع الشعوب الحره
على الجميع التي ما زالت يهمها قضايا
الانسان وقيمه ان تقف موقفا صارما من
النظام السوري وحلفائه ايضا والا هل نحن
في عصر قطاع الطرق ما يفعله الروس هو شكل
من ممارسات قطاع الطرق عندما يحمون
المجرمين
بجرائمهم الموصوفه وعندما يشكل مجلس الامن
لجان لجان تحقيق ولا يعترف الروس بها وقد
شاركوا بانشاء هذه اللجان
هذك سوابق سيد جورج دعني اتحول بهذا
السؤال للسيد سمير بوري ضيفنا من لندن
هناك سوابق يعني ونتساءل حقيقه عن جدوى
التحرك على مستوى مجلس الامن قرارات سابقه
القرار
2118 الذي اصدر في اعقاب المجزره الشنيعه
في الغطه الشرقيه يعني ضربت به روسيا عرض
الحائط والنظام السوري ومن هنا تساؤل ما
جد واي تحرك على مستوى مجلس الامن واي
قرارات يمكن ان تصدر في وجود هذا الفيتو
وفي ربما ظل هذا
عدم المبالاه اللامبالاه بخصوص اي قرار قد
ينتج مجلس الامن التابع للامم المتحده ليس
امامه اي خيار هناك الكثير من القرارات
التي تم اصدارها ولم تطبق نتذكر ما حدث في
2013 وايضا الهجمات التي تلت ذلك
تم التوصل الى نتائج التحقيقات في 201 بعد
استخدام الازلع السؤال الذي يجب ان يطرح
الان لدينا منظمه منظمه دوليه لحضر
استخدام الاسلحه الكيميائيه هي منظمه
موجوده في الهاي وعملت مع الام متحده في
الهجوم المنصرم في 2013 هل بامكان هذ هذه
المنظمه ان تقدم دلائل دامغه حول الجهه
التي تقف وراء هذا الهجوم بالاسلحه
الكيميائيه في سوريا السؤال الاج ارجوك
جنبنا الحديث عن هذا الموضوع حتى لا ندخل
في متاهه اخرى و موضوع يوجع القلب فعلا
نتذكر تماما ذلك الاتفاق الامريكي
والروسي على اخلاء او حتى سحب الاسلحه
الكيمياويه من النظام السوري وراينا الن
مجازر كالتي حدثت في خان شيخون بالتالي
السؤال هل من مسالك اخرى ما الذي بقي من ل
هؤلاء يعني هم حتما قد قضوا ومن بقي منهم
لا يريدون ان يتباكى العالم عنهم بل خطوات
يعني فعليه ما اقصى الممكن باعتقادك هل من
مسالك
اخرى للاسف الشديد يبد ان هناك غياب تام
لاي بدائل وخيارات اخرى والسبب هو ان
الروس ضيقوا الخناق بشكل كبير ولم يدعوا
اي خيارات ولا امكانيات اخرى مطروحه على
الطاوله وقدموا الدعم المطلق
للاسد تحدث ترامب كما قلتم قبل قليل وقال
انه سيتبنى موقفا جديدا لا اعتقد انه
سيكون هناك موقف جديد لن يستخدم الرئيس
ترامب القوه العسكريه ضد نظام الاسد خاصه
ان العلاقات طيبه وايجابيه ما
بين بوتين
وترامب نعم كان هناك اتفاق في 2011 وتمت
هناك
تحقيقات من قبل منظمه حضر استخدام الاسلحه
الكيميائيه لا ادري ما جدوى هذا الاتفاق
وهل سيتم البناء عليها ايضا الان سيد جورج
وانت عضو في لجنه المفاوضات هل لدى بقي
لدى من يطالبكم بالاستمرار في نهج التفاوض
والاصرار عليه اي حجه بعد الذي
حدث حقيقه من دون شك انما جرى و ويجري
يلقي بضلال ق قاتمه ليس على المفاوضات
وحدها انما على العمليه السياسيه برمتها ا
كيف يمكن ان يجري الحديث عن عمليه سياسيه
وهناك عمليات اباده جماعيه تتم ليس من قبل
النظام السوري بل من داعميه في ايران ومن
تغطيه من الضامن الروسي الذي يقدم نفسه
كداعيه للحل السياسي وضامن حقيقه السوريون
يتساءلون هل هي عمليه سياسيه ام تغطيه
للجرائم المستمره
بافتكر السوري وهذا سؤال له موقعه بالفعل
لكن هل يعدم العالم ان يتصرف في حمايه
السوريين يجب ان لا يحصل ذلك يجب ان يكون
هناك حظر جوي على طيران بشار الاسد فوق
جميع المناطق لان هذا الطيران هو الوسيله
الوحيده التي تحمل اداه القتل التي يرسلها
بشار الاسد للسوريين الابرياء اشكرك جزي
الشكر سيد جورج صبره عضو الهيئه العليا
للمفاوضات لقوى الثوره السوريه كنت معنا
من اسطنبول كما نشكر جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من
لندن سمير بوري المحاضر في الدراسات
الامنيه في كينجز كولج